come back it was a big weekend for the
NFL but what about former players some
are dealing with depression and
substance abuse during this pandemic
Bianca Holman shares how a former
football player is helping to break that
cycle for many sports fans football is
the epitome of excitement and
camaraderie from the 50-yard line to the
tailgaters in the parking lot it's the
life Derrick price knows as a former
Detroit Lions Titans
imagine walking into work and a hundred
thousand people stand up and clap for
you that's every Sunday right and then
all of a sudden then like one fail swoop
whether it's just your time or you get
an injury or whatever they're like yeah
you don't live this life anymore
in order to stay relevant and on the
field some athletes self-medicate to
keep going pushing through injuries
there's not like this gradual you know
off-ramp it's you were playing today and
then tomorrow you're out you're out of
the league well unfortunately your
habits carry with you right and some of
those guys may have abused the pills a
little bit felt too deep into the bottle
whatever and then you know multiplied
out with the depression of maybe their
lifelong dream is over Bryce says the
stress of the koban night teen pandemic
can trigger bad habits for those
struggling with addiction that's why the
NFL Alumni Association partnered with
American addiction center to provide a
lifeline for former players their
spouses and children we put about three
million dollars worth of care up and
we're saying hey we've given it to be
easy and we're like use this judiciously
for him to reach back and for his
company to be so generous as to think
about the guys that he played with and
the guys that are struggling and and not
as successful as he has been and to make
this offer is incredible Ries and rice
recognize there's a fight to end the
stigma surrounding addiction they hope
this program encourages our current and
former heroes on the field to ask for
help our job our responsibility with the
NFL alumni is to help guys live better
in retirement and I would rather have
somebody upset with me and saying like I
can't believe you reached into my
personal life I can live with that
better than living with the fact I
didn't say anything
and they od'd him passed away Bianca
Holman 8 News now
and price offers the hotline number to
desert hope you can see that number
right there eight eight eight nine eight
three zero nine two seven